Une erreur historique, a ditmaie
Plante, qui est avec nous on
dirait que ce soit.
- Bonsoir, M. Roy.
- On avait dit que ça pouvait
être intéressant, mais dans le
acheté?
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- Malgré toutes les bonnes
n'en demeure pas moins des gros
ligne au centre-ville. Quand on
écoutait les experts et les
citoyens, quand je parle des
experts, autant en urbanisme :
on ne peut pas faié
comme ça au centre-ville.
avec l'eau du bain.
- On va en parler du bébé. Mais
la structure, ça, c'était unc'ée
condition qui faisait que ça ne
marchait pas.
que ça n'allait jamais marcher?
- On a regardé de tous les
côtés...
l'époque?
- Justement. Quand je vous
tous côtés, on se demandait si
ça pouva et si ça
pouvait fonctionner. La réponse
au final, c'est non.
Quand on veut s'assurer que on
pas une cicatrice
urbaine, et c'est cela que ça
faisait. Alors on n'a pas le
- On voit les images de cette
rupture qui n'existera jamais.
Est-ce qu'il n'y aura pas...Est-
ce qu'il n'y a pas un manque
ation? Et on se dit
d'abord que ça ne marchera
jamais avant de la vallée de
l'essayer. Parce qu'il n'y aurat
de Montréal et l'ouest de la
ville.choses. choses. choses. cd
vous dîtes : il faut le faipourt
quand même des milliards de
dollars. On le fai les
prochaines années. On voyait
dans les villes dans les autres
pays, on voyait très peu de
villes qui montaient lessibilite
ça soit vandalisé, que ça soitcs
sont extrêmement grandes. Ce qui
est du lien, quand j'ai apprishu
premier ministre, c'est de
garder les se qui fonctionne, la
branche de l'Est et du Nord.
Mais il r la ligne verte qui
vaille notre façon de rentrer au
centre-ville de façon rapide. On
- On va peut-être voir sur la
transportransportransportranspoe
sur la ligne verte du métro.
- Exactement. C'est un enjeu on
se rappellera qui était dans le
était critiqué aussi, c'est
qu'on n'en parlait pas. On avaie
verte, il n'y avait aucune
connexion.- Si on arrive un moùa
liberté saturée, on fait quoi?
Parce qu'il faut voir un projet
n'est pas une courte vue de
verte, merci bonsoir!
pas survivre si on le garde dans
la forme actuelle, parce que à
ne peut pas enfoncer dans le
fond de la gorge un projet que
les gens ne voulaient pas.
Il y avait énorm
réticences dans le quartier de
de Maisonneuve. Pour moi et le
premier minute, et c'est là que
c'est qu'on va tout faire pour
que le transport dans l'Est...
on ne veut pas perdre cet
ne l'impression que le courant a
aussi bien passée entre vous et
même temps ce n'était pas une
le, parce que
vous allez participer à ce
projet, mais on revient à zéro.
moi, aujourd'hui, c'est une
rement, si on ne
faisait rien, ce projet allait
mourir, c'est évident parce
s
l'acceptabilité sociale, pour
une grande partie du tracé.Infrt
développé...
on ne parle absolument pas de
zéro. Et finalement, ce que
- Qui va dessiner?al,t la ville,
vous allez dire ça n'en fait
beaucoup du monde
- La voi
- On omi, on a décidé
de revoir les paramètres. Et moi
je suis convaincu qu'un projet
public cde l'Est, il
va fonctionner. Mais, je ne vous
cacherairnement rnement rnementr
exemple à ce projet des devis
similaires à l'ces difficultés,
ations. Ilations. Ilations. Ilae
donne les moyens aussi.
- Très bien. On verra.des commee
Montréal et déçu aujourd'hui
transport digne de ce nom
collectif entre l'Ouest et le
centre-ville?
- Honnêtement, le premier
ministre et moi on ne dit qu'on
échéancier. On devait aller au
printemps au BAPE,
perdu quelques mois. Mais jenote
même, le même c
quelques mois près.quelques moi.
- On va voir.
J'aimerais vous croire sur
parole, mais vous comprenez
pourquoi on peut être sceptique.
On garde ce qui fonctionne et o.
- Madame la maires
suivre ça. C'était une grosse
journée! Vous dites que ça fait
mais ça n'a profité.
faut prendre des décisions qui